j'ambitionne mère écrit m avira d'une
manière vous avez écrit une lettre à
giral hier concernant votre amour de la
paix alors à l'iss et à qui je te lire
donc généralement quand on n était pas
la poubelle
géraldine comme le disait le philosophe
christophe maé je suis tombé sous le
charme
avant j'étais un coureur de jupons un
homme à femmes ou encore comme tu aime à
le dire un connard je sais que tu penses
que notre amour est impossible alors je
voulais simplement offrir mon coeur est
de proposer une orgie de bonheur ce
magnon prescripteurs
ben tiens tu lis le pass crypto scriptum
c'est quand même très bonne pour ton âge
je suis toujours senti très sentimental
vous êtes surtout très con merci bonne
s'accomplirait le post scriptum story
puis j'aimerais dire a dit je suis dit
après alors j'en lis tu m'as tout fait
[Musique]
et tout fait aussi bon tu as commencé
par une sorte déclaration révélation
saugrenue de semaine puis après tu as
été bibliothécaire complètement inculte
suis joueur de tennis du dimanche puis
crooner de karaoké puis hier
agriculteurs scato alors visiblement
tuée en edge pour l'addiction mettait
aussi en edge pour la compréhension
hashtag mauvais sniper hashtag pied
d'egalite' hague lourdeur hashtags top
hashtag passe à autre chose
hashtag merci beaucoup ça c'est à dire
[Applaudissements]
alors je crois que la médiation pour moi
ça veut dire oui ou non à votre ami
c'est pas loin dit oui alors il m'a dit
je pense franchement et du moins bon
maintenant il y en a il ya que du
matériel
je pense que ces noms dont la non
négatif que des noirs voilà donc je vous
dis des dispositifs si c'est non voilà
donc ces noms géraldine c'est non
absolument
ça sera non toute la vie ah oui toute la
vie d'accord bernie tu écoutais
malheureusement vous venez de prendre la
plus grosse de l'histoire de l'émission
je rappelle qu'avec la paire n'a pas dû
assurer une belle donc d'accord et ben
voilà jean michel vous allez vous en
remettre
oui mais où map difficilement les jeux
et jeux choix quelle sera ta pub on dit
tout de suite j'aime ça formidable
michèle laroque
cela répondait le doute j'y crois pas
[Applaudissements]